on a quelqu'un qui s'appelle charles qui
est dans le public il n'a jamais couché
avec une fille charles il est au chat
merci charles charles levé vous il
voulait témoigner ce soir merci d'être
avec nous charles vous pouvez vous lever
et courageux soir charles merci d'être
là vraiment vous allez 25 ans fait quoi
dans la vie je suis en bac pro dans la
maintenance des équipements industriels
un point d'en prendre le micro bien vous
êtes donc je suis en bac pro ou la
marque compte des équipements
industriels
d'accord pas très bien c'est très bien
alors vous n'avez jamais eu une relation
sexuelle n'est jamais ça ça vous dérange
pas juste de le dire comme ça à la télé
vous pour vos amis voilà son cours ans
et c'est pas les émissions de co
pourquoi alors est ce que c'est un choix
personnel ou bien ce que c'est parce que
vous n'avez pas trouvé l'occasion ou la
fille qui vous plaît assez pour en avoir
avec elle ou le gars ont trouvé plutôt
logique d'un jeune de chemise non merci
non je revois le soir le rachat mais
après ça va merci alors charles donc non
je n'ai jamais voilà une attirance assez
importante pour une pour une fille pour
aller au bout c'est ça oui au fait je
ris je peux conclure que je suis du coup
gilles macé ce à quoi le vicieux chan
qui n'arrivent pas à conclure avec les
filles charles quint tu dis conclure
pardonne moi de te tutoyer mais tu es
rentré dans les détails
quand mon fils tu flirte même pas où tu
flirt et chariots pas passé le cap
dollars jamais voulu heurter avec une
fille tu veux ma tamponné je me propose
est évident en fait c'est ça oui timide
deux sessions fait que vous arrivez de
copains avec des filles parce que
franchement un peu mais peut être que
positif parce que je vous dis la vérité
charles franchement et je le dis
sincèrement il est très mignon chars oui
oui l'est pas c'est pas moi c'est vrai
trouvé plein de meuf je te le dire rien
mais moi j'ai trouvé donc
[Rires]
non je te jure physiquement et il est
très mignon charles franchement il est
plutôt et nourrit la démo yeux et
qualité c'est ce que manifester de suite
non mais c'est ça oui c'est vrai donc
charles c koi tu n'es pas un froid tate
à jaime une radio est ce que tu crois
qu'un blocage t'arrives pas à à dire
voilà que deux à passer le cap
d'embrasser une fille donc tu t'attends
qu'une fille fasse le premier pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe nous sommes
bloqués je fais tes fléchi j'y arrive
pas elle verrait le jeu mais même être
les réseaux sociaux par exemple
maintenant c'est qu'on sait ça devient
la mine ont peu derrière un écran
développer des relations et puis
peut-être se mettre en confiance même ça
ça vous bloque ah ouais alors elle l'a
stéphane edouard qui est dans le public
les parties stéphane on acheter des
idées à stéphane stéphane justement vous
avez écrit un livre qui dit cinq ans que
le son pour séduire quand vous voyez le
cas de charles pasque charge quoi vous
avez très envie d'avoir une relation de
d'avoir une fiancée voilà et ça ça vous
pourrit la vie ou vraiment quotidien ou
pas du tout si ce que beaucoup de mes
amis qu'on parle donc on vous dise quoi
vos amis je vais changer mon style que
nous devons changer mon style au fond je
trouve pas alors franchement je vous dis
la vérité je le dis je pense vraiment je
trouve que franchement le rabais est le
problème c'est pas c'est pas ton style
mais si tu veux il faut pas se tromper
c'est pas extérieurement que tu as
besoin d'évoluer comme un garçon comme
comme tous les autres qui a quatre
charmantes à tes qualités étaient des
faux c'est une thériault mince et
psychologiques un blocage psychologique
est ce que tu t'es ma c'est toi est ce
que tu te désire assez charles est ce
que tu peux répondre à ces questions on
oublie juste physiquement trouve de
cochons sont alors charles voyagiste je
te le dis ah non mais vraiment ah non
merde tu te prends la tête alors est ce
que tu es accompagnés par quelques noms
stéphane stéphane edouard sociologue
donc je les dis là est craintif 50e sont
pour séduire qu'est ce que vous pourriez
dire à charles quels conseils pour
aiguiller alors bravo au titre du livre
vous avez series chez les éditeurs qui
choisissent les titres donc le accord en
fait c'est 50 leçons pour saignement
fait sert la livre de cuisine
un livre de l'école les hommes mais pas
marion m'a dit il faut faire un petit
peu plus tassier donc mais tu mets ça
comme titre et c'est nous qui décidons
parce que c'est nous l'éditeur d'accord
à travers donc les titres de livres
c'est souvent comme ça par rapport à
charles
c'est un conte prénom c'est ça oui pour
moi c'est ni à l'extérieur ni intérieur
c'est simplement que tu es imbibé de ce
qu'on appelle la psy rose l'abc rose
c'est la psychologie à l'eau de rose
on en a entendu un petit peu ce soir
d'ailleurs consistant à baignés le
garçon d'à le faire communier dans la
chapelle de la bien-pensance à lui
dessiner une espèce de femmes qui
n'existe absolument pas et en gros
chaque fois qu'il est confronté à une
femme réelle
il est confronté il devient schizophrène
parce qu'il se rend compte qu'elle ne
fonctionne absolument pas comment lui
vend donc on lui vend une femme qui va
être sensible à sa timidité à sa poésie
à son introversion et c est en réalité
ils voient que dans le lait déterminant
réel de la traction ça va être la
notoriété le statut le bad boy l'enfoiré
et c est donc en réalité ils développent
une espèce de double dialogue avec un
qui nous tient ce soir mais dans mes ac
auquel il ne croit absolument pas et je
vous invite à regarder son sourire parce
que ça c'est quelqu'un qui l'a il a
compris qu'on a quelque chose devrait
donc y tient une espèce de discours
comme ça très accréditant pour les
femmes jean cagnard y soit parce qu'ils
devraient compenser qui jeu en tout cas
si je le dis c'est que c'est que je le
pense
là il a fait un bon diagnostic que si je
peux dire stéphane doiron pas du tout vu
de nos sites j'ai une question quels
conseils on pourrait lui donner juste
avant de moi ce que je lui conseille
c'est de désapprendre tout ce qu'on te
dit sur la femme et de regarder la femme
réelle en réalité tu l'idéaliste raw et
l'idéal ''sans trop tu es tu lui fournit
une espèce de discours préformaté un peu
faisandée frelaté qui l'intéressent pas
la femme reine n'est pas sensible à tata
bien pensants soit à tartas bienfaisance
est comme ça donc donc il faut qu'il
faut qu'ils passent outre tout ça il
faut qu'il arrive à surmonter ce à quoi
il faut qu'il arrive à ne plus projeté
devant ses yeux ce qu'il a derrière la
tête il faut qu'il arrive à regarder
vers cros jusqu'au cou
en affaires du musique et il est rentré
chez lui là arrivent à se départir d'un
discours féministe qui contraint
beaucoup d'hommes à rester seul et à
finir avec extra et à nourrir une
rancoeur sans cesse croissante envers
les femmes
voilà alors mais je dis vous aviez une
question pour pour ça si effectivement
tu n'arrives pas à l'etrat tirer enfin
tu n'arrives pas à conclure avec une
femme est ce que tu as déjà et c'est
avec un mec non non non mais là vous
êtes attiré par les femmes
oui voilà nom qu'il a mais comment
gagner a dit comment tu peux savoir être
attiré par les femmes si tu sais pas ce
que c'est mais non mais cela n'a rien à
mes ça n'a rien à voir
en fait tu dis des conneries ce sera
beaucoup question de tout à l'heure je
l'adorent j'aime beaucoup me dit mémé
jeudi frérot là il et il sait qu'il a il
sait qu'il est attiré par plainte ait
attiré par trente femmes et il attend
comme on dit après s'être tu as eu des
reçus ou bien tu as même car ils
m'aiment pas jusque là mais j'ai eu
beaucoup de refus à voilà bon bah non
c'est déjà bien mais c'est le problème
vient des lilas charles est ce qu'il ya
un type de femme quand tu fermes les
yeux dans l'absolu qui t'attire plus
qu'une que qu'un autre type est ce que
tu es plus blonde que que brune en
question intéresse les gardois pas le
cas il ya un signe de vie est obligé de
répondre faut lui dire c'est qu'il faut
qu'il soit accompagnée des moyens dont
c'est le métier voilà madame
d'agissements justement j analyse
sexologue est ce que est ce que vous
auriez vous aussi un conseil à donner à
charles est ce que c'est quelqu'un qui
devrait peut-être venir voir je sais pas
des dites nous oui tout à fait
je pense qu'il faut que ça fait
effectivement il y ait une
une démarche de remise en question de
lui et c'est pas effectivement entourage
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose à
regarder à l'intérieur donc dans vos
rapports de votre rapport aux femmes en
règle générale et puis et puis peut-être
aux hommes aussi l'image des hommes
quelle confiance en vous vous avez
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un homme face à
une femme et donc du coup interrogé
aussi l'image de l'homme
et puis moi je pense que c'est vraiment
s'ils se connecter à ton instinct primal
que la femme ce qui va la tirer c'est
aussi l'homme qui va dégager quelque
chose est en fait là je sens charles que
quoi que tu que tu retiens débloquer il
faut vraiment travailler mais en fait ça
se travaille
ça se travaille vraiment avec et ça se
débride
je voulais je voulais dire qu'en fait on
les hommes de plus en plus moi dans ma
clinique je sais pas si c'est pareil
mais moi je veux je vois de plus en plus
d'hommes qui ont des troubles du désir
qui ont de moins en moins confiance en
eux qui ce ton qui ont du mal à se
situer face à une femme qui bac est
sorti de la soumission qui ce qui
s'affirme est qui et qui fait que
l'homme est en demande de tendresse
beaucoup plus qu'avant alors que il
bénéficie d'une image avait bénéficié
il souffre plutôt d'une image médiatique
qui est plutôt agressif plutôt négative
et donc du coup il est complètement en
porte-à-faux un homme avec bon ce qui se
passe en ce moment médiatiquement les
les hashtags balance t'emporte mitu etc
c'est déjà suspect presque d'être un
homme et sa balance quelque chose de
négatif alors que dans l'ordre dans ce
que je vois moi c'est jeanne dielman
groupes de paroles d'hommes par exemple
eh bien il souffre beaucoup de cette
image là parce qu'ils sont heureux ils
se reconnaissent pas ils sont deux
hommes qui sont les réduire eric
naulleau ya la solution psychanalytique
sexologue et jérôme
vous devez amener un peu l'exemple c'est
beau ce qui est vrai c'est vrai il faut
une bonne copine comme moi il viendra un
moment au cap d'agde c'est vrai que je
joue ça vous dirait charles nonsard
franchement moi je crois que c'est la
solution
est-ce que c'est pas trop mal mais à la
seule loi y est la cause que tu lui
demandes de la cour jeu d'être venu ah
oui dur je voudrais poser une question à
charles charvet aujourd'hui on sait bien
que c'est pas comme il ya quelques
décennies
les filles elles n'attendent pas
toujours d'être dragué le dragon peut
aussi quand elle trouve un garçon
charmant
tu as chairman tu as des qualités elton
ragots parfois les filles et peut-être
qu'il veut alors que tu ne sens pas moi
je vais vous le dire mais c'est
compliqué agathe franchement on va
battre chalon moi je trouve très heureux
je trouve franchement très mignon et je
pense si charles que tu veux que je
voudrais la vie d'une unis voilà le
problème du même âge de ton physique de
ton corps et c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est
que ça se passe dans ta tête
un blocage d'une timidité presque
maladive et c'est vrai que ça c'est
pathologique c'est quelque chose que tu
dois pas aller travailler pour t'ouvrir
et tu vas trouver l'amour et tu vas être
très sûr en cause la gratuité minutes et
open bar la mine
arrêtez moi si quelqu'un que j'avais la
confiance en moi du tout attendez il ya
un témoignage là c'était quelqu'un avant
qu'ils n'avaient pas confiance en moi et
franchement j'ai envie de te dire un
truc pelé toi toi déjà toi même avant de
vouloir plaire aux autres exacto pop aux
pauvres en une émission il est passé de
jessica des marseillais à nietzsche
[Applaudissements]